you are the trailer park
i am the tornado
it's 38 even
care to donate to the jar fund sure
i'm
good
you know you should start a gofundme
page
what's that
it's um
it's a pickle jar the whole world can
reach
your boy
dealing with this i still have that to
you
someone's doing it to you
too not any more than that
how
how did you make him stop
my boyfriend put his head through a wall
then i smashed a skull with an
eight-pound ashtray
new boyfriend
big-ass ashtray
it was just a thought
see the women in this valley have gotten
a lot more fashionable
yeah
and see chippendales changed their
policy on capped teeth
what's that
it's an insult
never mind only an insult if i
understand it yeah that's not true but
that's a conversation for another time
that we'll never have
that'd be easy to assassinate
don't tempt me i'm not trespassing
but it's not our land
it's not the first time you've done that
you know i ran out of things to do for
the first time when i was 20.
that thing's quite a picture yeah feel
free to beat off to it later
who am i kidding you only do that in
front of the mirror right
schwarzenmaier shorting our stock
is like a terrorist bombing a subway
it doesn't stop the subways and it
doesn't destroy the cities the subway
serves just hurts some people and not
the people you want to hurt but it does
make the people you want to hurt
i want to hurt you back
you're going to try and hurt me back
is that what you're trying to say
hmm
because i've been down this road many
many times before buddy
and no one who tried it is alive to tell
you how poorly that worked out for him
well you say you're gonna hire a [ __ ]
hit man to come after me if i come after
you
i thought you moved to salt lake
i did
then i moved here
had enough of l.a huh
when bearded hipsters started riding
scooters to work i got out of there i
hate that place
[Music]
my dad told me once there will come a
day
and the only noble job left is fishing
so no one's figured out a way down the
ocean
yeah that's right
i'm working on it
i bet you are
find the flowers when you leave
will do
[Music]
i like this girl
wow
[Music]
oh
what in the [ __ ] are you doing now
in 35 years
i have never been alone on this ranch
you've been doing whatever you want your
whole damn life but no one can see us we
could take off all our clothes
we could go run nicky through the field
no i would know about it i'll tell you
what why don't you run butt house snakes
for that field and i'll sit here in my
jeans and i'll watch you do it what do
you say
is there anything you ever wanted to do
but you didn't do
because everybody would watch you
question you and now doing it is in
spite of them and it's about something
else
and the moment you imagined it is not
the moment that you are
does that make sense to you
um
uh honestly i don't even know what you
just said
[Music]
when all this is over
i'm gonna hang your diploma above my
toilet in my guest house
yeah i'm not worried
like i said you gotta let the sting fade
[Music]
then we'll talk
this thing never fades with me
it is a painful lesson
and one you're about to learn
don't pretend like you don't know how we
fight
oh i know how you fight
i subscribe to nietzsche's thoughts on
right and wrong
he was a german philosopher died of
syphilis after he cornholed some
prostitute
so not exactly a life to model yours
after
but his thoughts not right and wrong
good and evil
which were
there's no such thing
that i believe
i believe in loving with your whole soul
and destroying anything that wants to
kill what you love
that's it
that's all there is
i believe in the same thing
you can keep this secret
oh if you excuse me
i gotta kill someone too
it's settled
we'll get married
married
yeah baby i'm asking you to marry me
will you do that
i mean i
i would have to ask your father now
it's handled
he spares you the indignity
so what'd he say
i mean i
was like sometimes actually
yeah yes
beth i can't go to the courthouse
there's no record i even exist on this
planet
yeah well
marriage license that's just a contract
okay it's just
business
we ain't going into business together
so marriage to me is
can you take me one of those mountains
in front of my family
my friends
i don't have any friends but should i
make one
you would stand in front of them
and you would tell them that there is no
more you and i
there's only us
i can do that
[Music]
so
[Music]
you